[Music]
how are you i'm fine thank you we're
used to relentlessly good news on the
vaccine program as people stream into
centers like this
in reading more came today as it emerged
that nine in ten
seventy year olds now have coronavirus
antibodies
the health secretary was bullish we have
now vaccinated
over 25 million people across the united
kingdom
the vaccine is saving thousands of lives
right now here in the uk and it can give
us all hope
emphasizing the positives of which there
are plenty but
sidestepping significant bad news
just moments before he spoke this letter
from nhs england revealed
there will be a significant reduction in
weekly supply available from
manufacturers beginning in the week
commencing the 29th of march
meaning volumes for first doses will be
significantly constrained
meaning that inviting patients outside
of cohorts one to nine
is only permissible in exceptional
circumstances
those aged 49 years or younger should
not be offered vaccination unless they
are eligible via a higher cohort
they go on to say that no further
appointments should be made between the
1st
to the 30th of april the health
secretary though seemed dismissive
supply is always lumpy and of course you
know these supply schedules have
moved up and down throughout this whole
rollout it's
absolutely uh par for the course
and um it is a that that's why it's a
you know that is a normal operational
uh letter we're committed to all adults
being able to get the
jab by the end of july
and we're on track to deliver on that
commitment
the government's commitments were always
ones they knew they could meet
today's announcement still matters
though says the opposition
it's clearly very worrying it's quite
significant that uh vaccination
uh appointments have had to be will have
to be paused for a whole month
nobody was expecting an issue of this
scale not least because
boris johnson keeps boasting about his
vaccination program well
people tonight deserve clarity and an
explanation from ministers
those very ministers are acting as if
they think that people won't notice the
vaccine slow down
because the rollout has gone so well
generally to date
but people are obsessed with when
they're going to get the jab and telling
all under 50s that now won't happen
until may
will rankle down playing or even
ignoring bad
news is something some people think matt
hancock
and his department have formed for
do you feel like there's more that could
have been done that criticism came
earlier in the day from boris johnson's
right-hand man until november
dominic cummings who admitted big flaws
in the pandemic response and pointed the
finger of blame
in spring 2020 you had a situation where
department of health was just
a smoking ruin in terms of procurement
and ppe and all of that
it's not coincidental that the vaccine
program worked the way that it did
it's not coincidental that to do that we
had to take it out of
the department of health the people in
here don't want to dwell on the mishaps
of last year
but could today's announcement be more
than a bump in the road
sam coates sky news